hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
new Star Wars trailer coming they posted
a quick teaser so there's gonna be a
breakdown of this as well as the poster
there are a couple new things on the
poster that we haven't seen yet so the
biggest thing about this new footage is
that we see Finn in rebel gear really
the two options here are that Finn
starts out as a rebel or he starts out
with the empire and becomes a rebel you
can kind of see one of the black x-wings
here that he's walking by Daisy really
of course still on jakku that's the
planet where she and Finn meet up you'll
actually if you play the star wars game
the the battlefront game they're
releasing this holiday season you will
be able to see that they have some
special DLC called the battle of jakku
so it takes place like right before Star
Wars Episode seven picks up the super
weapon up here in the upper right hand
corner of this poster belongs the empire
looks a lot like the Death Star probably
somewhere near the Starkiller base if
you remember the Starkiller base was
named just in honor of Luke Starkiller
elite you know the original name for
Luke Skywalker and George Lucas's first
script the actual base is on the ice
planet we've seen the surface of that
with atom drivers character and these
these promos here and we've seen the
inside of it in the last trailer now
this promo obviously has a lot of stuff
that you've seen before like we see
captain phasma's character we see the
first order stormtroopers and if you
look in the background here it looks
like we're seeing masks kanata for the
first time
Lupita's character she's doing a motion
capture role just like andy serkis is
now andy serkis is playing supreme
leader snoke probably not gonna be in
any of the marketing materials it'd be
like putting the emperor on the first
original Star Wars poster the other
really big thing we have to talk about
is the lack of Luke Skywalker now they
were kind of open about this several
months ago where they were like we're
you know we're not gonna be putting Luke
Skywalker in any of our marketing
materials but he will carry over in
Episode eight that you know there is a
rumor that some original trilogy member
or at least one of them could die but I
think the likely candidate would be han
Solo because Harrison Ford really only
gets excited for interesting stories and
he said like a long time ago when they
were shooting Return of the Jedi he
really wanted George Lucas to kill Han
Solo in that third movie but of course
George Lucas being an enterprising
businessman was like I'm not gonna kill
one of my most popular characters so I
think now that they're trying to
transition to the new cast the the
producers of Star Wars Kathleen Kennedy
all those people will be much more open
to killing off Han Solo given that he is
an old man now and he probably wouldn't
be long for the galaxy anyway
let me know what you guys think of the
poster so what's happening next is is
they're gonna be posting a full trailer
during ESPN's Monday Night Football I
know that sounds good I'll explain why
in a second and I'll totally be doing a
video for it and I'm gonna be giving
away my reverse flash ring from my flash
arrow Q&A so if you've if you've been
following like the flash giveaways just
just because so much happened and I
wasn't able to do that video I'm gonna
give away the ring in the Star Wars
trailer video I think it's pretty
reasonable to assume that everybody that
watches my flash videos will watch that
Star Wars trailer video plus Mark Hamill
speaking of some common ground Mark
Hamill will be back for the flash season
two so if you really like his trickster
character from season one he'll totally
be back but just to explain why they're
posting a new Star Wars trailer during
Monday Night Football of all places it's
because the ratings are so high they
want people to see the trailer and go
see the movie that normally wouldn't be
trolling the internet for that kind of
footage think about it this way you guys
that are watching this in me we're a
huge Star Wars fans so of course we're
gonna like have our ear to the ground
for any kind of new footage new images
stuff like that but there are a lot of
people that just have no awareness for
that
that's what Monday Night Football is for
advance ticket sales are also going to
open Monday so if you want to make sure
that you don't get shut out on the 18th
whenever the movie comes out you like
you want to buy your ticket right now
you can do that on Monday night if you
have an IMAX theater somewhere near
where you live I would advise that you
see it in IMAX because they did use an
IMAX camera for a bunch of very special
sequences where you can totally do it
like me and you can go see it like a
regular theater and see it in IMAX there
aren't a whole lot of movies that I
would go see more than once but Star
Wars is definitely one of those
franchises shut up and take my money
so everybody look out there's gonna be a
walking dead video later tonight but
then that Star Wars trailer will post on
Monday night so get hype just in case
you guys haven't seen it there been a
bunch of other Star Wars teasers and
trailers that I've posted you can click
here to watch all those and you can
click here for the Game of Thrones video
that I just posted all about ashara
dayne
thank you so much for watching everybody
what's that Bob I'll see you guys
tonight
you